[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime newscast
the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments and
if you're wondering why it sounded a
little strange today
I'm actually dealing with a cold which
is totally weird cuz it's almost
springtime here in Canada I mean just
yesterday I was like hanging out on my
back porch enjoying the great beautiful
day enjoying some tropical Brazilian
rhythms it was great the big news for
this week is that a second season of the
anime Overlord has just been confirmed
and the announcement actually came
during a screening of the second
overlord compilation film and of course
this is great news for overlord fans but
I also think it's very interesting that
we're getting announcements about new
seasons coming during screenings of
compilation and recap films and I'm
wondering if this trend is going to
continue in the future
especially with anime like Code Geass we
know that Code Geass is going to have
several recap films before a third
season comes out so I wonder if during
the screenings of these films we're
going to get previews of the third
season perhaps are an exact release date
that would be awesome I can't wait to
find out and if you're wondering when
the Code Geass recap films are going to
be coming out we still don't know there
is still no release date however we are
checking daily and as soon as we know we
will let you know in other news this
week on rant cafe on Thursday 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time
we're going to be roasting that anime
snobs novel joining me for this stream
we're going to have cyanide blizzard and
Briggs from all the anime and maybe some
other special guests as well be sure to
tune in be sure to spread the word
because it's gonna be epic and also in
rant cafe news next week on March 23rd
we're going to have a very special guest
joining Rand cafe and I'm talking about
huge youtuber and a great guy too spooky
that's right too spooky is going to be
joining us foreign cafe and he makes
some great content on his channel fact
videos and in-depth analyses of his
favorite anime so be sure to check him
out and of course tune in for that
and cafe and I know what you're thinking
guys dude Anna Mac first you had Tony
the black Critic I join ran cafe he has
over 70,000 subscribers now 2spooky is
joining he has a hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers like who's next
are you gonna ask aki dearest to join
ran cafe or are you too much of a [ __ ]
and to that I have to say they asked me
how are you say that you're fine when
you're not really quietly speaking of
Aki dearest this week she made a video
in which she reenact some of the
figure-skating scenes from Yuri oh nice
inside a skating rink I thought this
video was hilarious I really enjoyed it
be sure to check it out and actually in
this video I found out that Aki's ice
skating skills are about on the same
level as my own with the only difference
being that she lives in a desert and I
live in Canada so yeah stop judging me
Canada okay
stop judging me in other news a whole
bunch of brand new character designs
have been revealed for the re0 light
novel including some mysterious magical
ladies without getting into any of the
light novel spoilers it is clear that
the hype for this franchise as a whole
just keeps growing and growing and I
really hope we get a season 2
announcement soon also this week the
enemy man uploaded a video about what he
will be watching during the 2017 spring
anime season if you're a fan of Joey
definitely check this out and I'm really
hoping that we can look forward to his
2017 anime seasonal roundups some time
before 2019 and for my favorite MV this
week I have to go with this top 10 best
school slash romance anime countdown /
MV by anime recon I mentioned before how
much I like the way recon combines our
top 10 countdown with an A MV and again
this one features such great editing
amazing music including a remix of
rising tides from Clannad I mean the
fields in this video are so real damn
you recon damn you you got me again oh
definitely check this out and that is it
for this week guys if you enjoyed these
videos be sure to LIKE and subscribe and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]